emergence is to me one of the most
exciting things that we can study in
science when patterns spontaneously form
in systems comprised of objects whether
they're atoms or molecules or or nano
particles or flocks of birds those
patterns are said to be emergent because
they're not evident by simply looking at
the individual constituents of the
system so for example when you look up
in the sky and you see these intricate
patterns that birds form when they're
when they're flying around those
patterns are nothing that you would have
guessed at if you just looked at the
birds and thought about how the birds
are flying next to one another or if you
take water and you freeze it into ice in
the freezer or you make a solution of
data particles and outcomes a
complicated photonic structure you would
never have guessed just by looking at
individual water molecule or individual
nanoparticles what those structures
would look like and so emergence
underlies so many different types of
questions in science from the kind of
traffic jams that you get from the
interactions of many cars in the roads -
even the origin of life and how complex
structures emerged from simpler
structures in my group we study
emergence by making mathematical models
of different kinds of systems and then
we solve these models using computers
usually very large very fast computers
and what's what's important about using
the computer is that we're able to strip
away one by one all the kinds of
interactions that might be present in a
system so that we can see the role of
all of the different interactions and
one of the contributions to emergence
that that my students and I are
particularly fascinated by is is the
idea of entropy entropy is typically
thought of as disorder and so the idea
that entropy can actually contribute to
order is sometimes surprising to people
but in fact entropy can be the cause of
emerge
and in many different different systems
and so that is something that's really
interesting to us